[موسيقى]
اشتياق العيش في المدينه يعني اقدر اقول
معدوم
[موسيقى]
عرفت على زوجتي
عن طريق الكنيسه
[موسيقى]
سليم نعمه كنا بنسكن ببغداد
حي حي الغدير
قبل السقوط كان زوجي عنده فكره انه نجي
للقريه
[موسيقى]
حتى نعيش هناك بالطبيعه
ولكن جدي شغله مال السقوط بغداد هاي
ساعدتنا عن نجي للقريه
قريبا
اكثر من 15 سنه ساكنين في القريه
بعيدا عن ضوضاء المدن وتلوث المدن حياه
تقريبا ريفيه هادئه بسيطه كيف اختارين انه
بالفعل شفنا بانه الحياه الريفيه
نوعا ما افضل من صخب المدينه بها هدوء
براحه بيتنان صح تقريبا تكون منعزل لكن
حياتك يعني بها استقرار نفسي ما بيها تشنج
ما بيها خبصه المدن ورباك المدن تكون
اعصابك نوعا ما هذا فلذلك قررنا نعيش
بالقرى والارياف اللي هي هاي قريتنا
[موسيقى]
اني بالكامل النباتيين ما
يعني نتطرق الى المشتقات الالبان او لحوم
او غيرها في حياتنا نباتيه عيوبنا اكثر
شيء هي فاكهه وخبز اللي خبز مصنوعه بالبيت
اللي هي
زوجه تصنع الخبز بالبيت
غيظانه نقدر نقول اشياء مثل كل العراقيين
الامور المطبوخه ما عدا اللحوم او الدجاج
او غيرها
وتقريبا العشا يكون خفيف اللي هي نوعا ما
مكسرات واشياء خفيفه او فاكهه مجففه
احنا كل شي نسوي
بايدينا تعلمنا هواي اشياء امي كانت تسوي
خبز انا قمت اخبز الاكل احنا اللي نسويه
نزرع وناكل
[تصفيق]
مزرعتي هي تقريبا مزرعتي اكثر شي هي يضم
التفاح
وازرع بها مثل ما تقول احتياجاتنا البيتيه
مثل الطماطم الخيار نزرع عدي فاكهه مثلا
تركي الو عندي يسموه السفرجل مزارع كاكي
مشمش عندي تقريبا اقدر اقول اغلبيه
الفاكهه اللي تطلع منطقتي عندي ومنطقتي ما
تعيش الا اشجار متساقطه الاوراق الاشجار
دائما الخضره ما تعيش لانجمادات توصل يمنا
19 20 تحت الصفر من كثافه الثلوج وغزارتها
[موسيقى]
بمجهوداتي الشخصيه عن طريق النت تعلمت
شلون اربي النحل شلون انتج ملكات وشلون
ازيد واكثف النحل تقريبا اربع خمس سنين
وصلت نحله من صندوقين الى ما يقارب تقريبا
900 الف صندوق بس دائما ما يبقى عندي لانه
انا شغلي حاليا هو بيع النحل وبيع الملكات
وبيع غذاء ملكي كل موسم يبقى عندي ميه الى
200 صندوق لا اكثر
[موسيقى]
شغلتي الاساسيه اني اقدر اقول الشغلات
الكبيره علي يعني مثلا الحرافه
تسوي سواقي تزرع السقي الاشياء البسيطه
اللي هي مثلا جني الثمار ترتيب الثمار
ترتيب الحديقه ترتيب المزرعه تكون على
زوجتي
بصراحه اشتياق للمدينه يعني شو اقول لك
يمكن واحد بالمئه
بس كاقارب عادي
كانوا في دهوك او ان كانوا في اربيل او ان
كانوا في والنواحي التابعه
في انترنت في تلفاز في ستلايت نتواصل مع
اي معلومات واي اخبار واي احداث بالعالم
تحدثت بحدث نقدر نتواصل ونعرفه ان كان عن
طريق الانترنت او الستلايت تواصل موجود ما
لانه اني عايش بالارياف ما عندي اتصال
تواصل عالمي لا موجود بس
التماسيل الاجتماعي شويه بعيد لكن التواصل
الاجتماعي لا موجود عن طريق النت
[موسيقى]